So the first one is, of course, rather obvious,
before you even start a search tree algorithm,
you should always apply pre-processing.
And the last one, of course, also doesn't make sense,
because once the search tree is completed,
then you already have your best possible solution
so why would you want to start pre-processing again.
The interesting part is this here,
because it could be the case that the assignments that you create
during your search tree algorithm
actually allow you to do new pre-processing rules,
and you have already seen this.
For example, for independent set and vertex cover
where we had said that during the search tree you come across cases
where for other vertices you can already decide if they are
going to be in an optimal solution or not, so it does make sense,
and there are the names of it misleading to apply
this pre-processing also during the search tree.
Now the question is, how often and when you should you should apply it.
You should definitely apply it regularly,
because you can regularly gain new
information during your search tree algorithm.
Doing it at each level, on the other hand, I think should not be  recommended,
and the reason for that is although pre-processing requires only polynomial time,
it still requires time, so if you do the pre-processing too often
then on the one hand you waste a lot of time,
and on the other hand, these rules will not be very effective
because you need to have made a few more decisions each time in the search tree
until new pre-processing rules might become applicable.
How often to apply it is almost more of an art than a science,
but you should definitely not think about pre-processing
as something that you do only before you start a search tree algorithm
but also something that can help you during a search tree.